today on the Matt Walsh show President
Trump wants to send $2,000 checks to
some many many Americans is that a good
idea some people are calling it
socialism or saying that it's like
Andrew Yang's universal basic income
plan
I think that's absurd it's it's neither
of those things clearly and I'll explain
why also the media has not let up on its
lecturing about why we shouldn't call it
the China flu or the come flu or the
Chinese flu or whatever else and this
this the the fact that they're focusing
on this of all things right now proves
exactly why we don't trust the media
can't trust the media and therefore we
don't know who to trust when things like
this happen and that just makes it all
the worse in in in a situation like this
so we're going to talk about that as all
as well plus five headlines including
the cringe East cringefest of a cringe
video that you will ever cringe at some
celebrities got together and decided
they wanted to inspire us during this
pandemic and you know that whenever
celebrities decide they want to inspire
us it's it's gonna be bad so we'll play
that video for you and in today's
cancellation I am as dangerous as this
may be for me personally I will be
cancelling my wife my wife is canceled
and hopefully she can't hear me right
now because we're all self quarantined
in the house while I am shooting this
video as we speak but there's very good
reason for it and I will explain why all
of that on the way but first let's check
in with our friends over at fairway
you know I I love all of our sponsors
this one especially is a very easy one
for me to try to sell because what it
comes down to is it's delicious meat
that is delivered right to your home and
and it makes life easier
especially these days when you've got
the you've got the delivery you don't
have to go out for it
and they're gonna deliver however much
you want and you could put it in the
freezer and you could save it so it's a
good idea to keep to keep food to have
it stored but also let's just focus on
the fact that it's it's really delicious
stuff that's what it comes down to town
down to fairway is
family-owned grocery chain that's been
in business since 1938 so they've got a
lot of tradition they've been doing this
for a long time and you could tell when
you when you taste the product fairways
premium beef and all-natural pork is
raised by family farmers and hand-cut by
a highly experienced team of fairway
butchers from Ridge two ribeyes pork
chops beef tenderloin they're certified
heritage pork is crafted in small
batches by Midwest family farms making
it the most succulent pork that you'll
ever taste fairway meat market calm its
fairway meat market calm also allows
free access to the best recipes and
cooking tips so your friends and family
have a meal they won't want to forget
and I've been i-i've had discovered
those those recipes as well so that's
that's that's great they're not just
gonna leave you with the meat and then
leave you on your own to try to figure
out how to cook it although honestly my
experience has been and I think this is
the case with with most delicious cuts
of meat it's just salt you want put some
salt on it a little bit of pepper you
don't want to overdo the season because
you want the flavor of the meat to come
out but you can find great recipes as
well at fairway meat market calm this
week my listeners can get the heartland
package valued at $230 for just $99.99
so you're getting that's over half off
plus free shipping when entering Walsh
at checkout the Heartland package
includes eight 8-ounce all-natural
boneless pork chops eight a six eight
ounce USDA choice ribeye steaks and then
one mouth-watering side dish which could
be loaded potato baked gourmet cheesy
corn or brisket baked beans that's more
than 50% off the best meat in America
Plus free shipping that's fairway meat
market calm promo code walsh and look
for the for the heartland package again
that's fairway meat market.com promo
code walsh look for the heartland
package okay so my plan right now is is
for this episode of the show to be the
last one where I talk about the China
virus for a while the last for a while
not the last ever but at least for for a
little bit that's my plan I can't
guarantee it will happen because I'm
very bad on follow-through in general
but also because it kind of depends on
what's going on in the news but I really
want to stop talking about this every
day because I feel like you the listener
are already consumed
as everybody else is and so you probably
don't need to hear it for me every day
that's my plan I'm already I've been
I've been planning for days now to have
what I'm going to call the no corona
show tomorrow but just to find stories
and things to report and talk about that
have nothing to do with the China virus
it's very difficult I mean every every
every website it's it's a about this but
so I'm planning on doing that tomorrow
right now though I do want to discuss a
couple things related to it because
there are you know I think of a few a
few important issues that I want to talk
about so I'm gonna kind of jump around a
little bit between this and that so bear
with me first of all the White House has
announced a plan to send stimulus
payments to American workers who are
suffering during the lockdown and the
quarantines and having their their jobs
taken away now it hasn't all been worked
out yet but the idea tentatively is to
send two checks of $1,000 apiece to
people who make under a certain amount
although that amount has not yet been
decided as far as I know the stimulus
stimulus package will also provide money
to a number of industries that have been
especially hurt by the outbreak in
response to it like the airline industry
there's there's little doubt that a bill
like this which already we're talking
about a trillion dollars probably gonna
end up being more there's no doubt that
there will be untold millions or
billions of dollars in pork and other
unrelated expenditures added into it and
we'll have to fight over that when the
time comes but the basic idea to send
relief to American families is good and
I am someone as you know if you watch
this show I am someone who is I'm the
last one to come out in favor of a
government handout I am normally opposed
to government handouts of nearly any
kind but this I would wholeheartedly
support I think it's a good idea from
the White House a few general points I
think need to be made about it number
one people on the left and people on the
right have argued that this would be
welfare or socialism so on the Left
they're saying oh so now now the
Conservatives want wealth or want
welfare or they think socialism is a
good idea
and in there there have been some
conservatives who are criticizing it and
saying I thought we weren't I thought we
were against socialism and then also
there's been the argument that this is
tantamount to the - Andrew Yang's
universal basic income plan none of that
is remotely the case
Yang's plan would give it would give
Americans a thousand dollars a month in
perpetuity systematically as an economic
system it's not a response to a not not
a temporary emergency response to a
pandemic it would be that's just the way
the system works socialism and Welfare
are again systems that go on without end
and work to make citizens dependent upon
the government the proposal from the
White House is entirely different it
would be a measure taken in response to
an unprecedented global crisis lots of
extraordinary things are happening right
now normal life and ways of doing things
have been upended for everybody and many
wet in many ways across the board so a
person can support under this
circumstance it would seem to me a
stimulus check without without granting
any credibility at all to socialism or
ubi or the welfare state also this is an
important point Americans are losing
money and jobs because the government
has shut down their places of employment
and told them to stay home so whether
you think those steps are justified or
not the result is that many people are
being prevented by the state from going
to their jobs and working and making
money so it seems only fair that state
would compensate them in that case
besides what other choice do we have
people need money they don't have it
because they can't work that's maybe
it's as simple as that
the second point some people have
pointed out some Republicans have
pointed out that families with children
would need more than single people and
others have worried that rich people and
people who are working from home like
myself we don't we don't need the money
because we we haven't had an
interruption in our paychecks so why
would you say that's something and and
and I agree that you know ideally you
don't want to send checks to people who
don't need it the problem though is how
is the government going to determine who
needs it who doesn't to go through that
of the government deciding that that's a
process that could take a long time but
it's not gonna do much good if these
checks are sent out after four months of
bureaucratic deliberation people need
the money now so you got to be quick
about it I think the better way and this
was a plan proposed I think I mentioned
it on the show yesterday proposed on
Twitter Josh barro and Twitter had the
idea that well maybe you just send the
money to everybody or you know everybody
under a certain everyone who is not very
wealthy that should be easy enough you
sent them to everybody and then and this
may seem enormous ly naive maybe it is
but and then you have a campaign a
social campaign encouraging people who
don't need the money to pass it along
I've already suggested now for something
like this you need a hashtag so I've
already suggested hashtag passed the
buck and if you get it check and you
don't need it because you already
because you're working from home and
your income is good and hasn't been
interrupted then you pass the check
along with somebody else I would be
perfectly you know I know my wife and I
would be perfectly happy to pass it
along to other people we know in our
lives who need it and I know that we're
certainly not alone I think many people
would like to do that the thing is you
know we talked about uniting and people
helping each other out well on Twitter
on social media you don't see a lot of
that people are tearing each other's
each other the shreds if you look at
Washington there's not a lot of unity
there but and anytime you try to
establish some sort of general unity you
know among millions and millions people
across the country that that what what
would that even mean but my point is in
individual communities I think Americans
are very good at being United and and
helping each other out in difficult
times and helping each other through
hard times and we this that's what
Americans do so I think you send the
checks out and then you leave it to
individual communities to help each
other out and I think that they will do
that now more to say about this in just
a moment but first because there's
another really important point about
this plan that I want to make that
separates it from socialism welfare
state ubi and so on but first let's
check in with LifeLock
you know to get your identity stolen
it's never happened to me I've talked to
people who's I've some people close to
me that's happened to and I it's it's
obviously a bad situation very
nerve-racking can be very costly it's
also it's also wildly inconvenient and
time-consuming you have no idea unless
you've been through it how
time-consuming it is to get through and
to and to sort out and during tax season
your name your Social Security lots of
available lots of valuable information
is out there being sent back and forth
and so there are a lot of opportunities
for the bad guys to come in and steal
that information and then on top of
dealing with taxes now you have to deal
with it with your identity being stolen
you don't want to have that trust me
that's why you need LifeLock the number
one most recognized brand an identity
theft protection
LifeLock monitors for uses of your
personal info alerts you to the possible
suspicious activity and if you become a
victim of identity theft a dedicated
identity restoration specialist will
work to fix it so you have the peace of
mind of knowing that you're being
protected from it but if something does
happen you also have that backup of
someone there who's going to help you
sort all the way through it now you can
take advantage of this I would
absolutely recommend it it's these days
it's just crazy it's like walking
through the street naked you don't want
to do that you don't want to be using
the internet sending private information
back and forth without having LifeLock
join now save up to 25 percent off your
first year just go to LifeLock comm
slash Walsh that's a LifeLock comm slash
Walsh for 25% off like fly flock dot-com
slash Walsh okay talking about this and
we'll move on to something else in
minute but talking about this this plan
to send checks up one other point third
third play this this goes I guess maybe
could go fold into point number one but
it's it's not welfare it's not socialism
because these are payments that are
going mostly to workers that is
taxpayers that's the whole point here is
to compensate people who can't work
because the government's told them they
can so you're compensating people for
the loss to work work they lost out on
because the government mandated it so
they're getting their own money back
they are their taxpayers they're the
ones filling the government's coffers
though that money that's being sent out
that's if you're a worker and you can't
and you've been working your whole life
and you can't go to work now because the
government shut everything now and you
get two thousand dollars you get two one
thousand dollar checks that's not
somebody else's money it's your money
you're the one that's been paying this
the government's been taking money from
you for years
so yeah you you're owed that I mean I
would I would call this an entitlement
in the literal sense of the word you're
entitled to it the government's been
taking money from you it's your money
now they're telling you you can't work
you need to work to feed your family
well basically what you're saying to the
government is I need some of that money
back and that's my own money you need to
give it back to me so I just think I
think that's important as well and
that's a big difference between that and
something like welfare where people who
are working are forced it's a forced
charity model where they're forced to
pay for people who mostly are not
working it's entirely different however
you feel about welfare it's an entirely
different thing both in terms of the
economics of it and philosophically okay
now um another thing I wanted to talk
about and this is this is a dumb
conversation
it is so remarkably incredibly
fantastically done but it's a
conversation the media wants to have the
conversation about whether it's it's
racist to call the coronavirus the
Chinese virus or the China virus Trump
was asked about this by a speaking of
fantastically dumb a very dim an
exceedingly dull reporter asked him
about this issue and I really loved his
response I think this is there's there's
a lot I like about this from from
trumpets it's it's nothing nothing
extraordinary you know but he doesn't
have some
snappy comeback where he's I'll he
demolished her he destroyed her it's not
that at all and that's what I like about
it so well let's just play the video
watch this why do you keep calling this
the Chinese virus there are reports of
dozens of incidents of bio bias against
Chinese Americans in this country
your only aid secretary is Iran says he
does not use this term because ethnicity
does not cause the virus why do you keep
using this as it comes to enjoying it
it's not racist at all no not at all
it comes from China that's why comes
from China I want to be accurate please
John I have a great I have great love
for all of the people from our country
but as you know China tried to say at
one point maybe this stuff now that it
was caused by American soldiers that
can't happen it's not gonna happen
not as long as I'm president it comes
from China reports of dozens of
incidents of bias against Chinese
Americans really what bias was that
people deciding not to eat at the
Szechuan walk down the street that's the
bias Panda Express has a slow a slow
lunch hour now it's a hate crime against
Chinese people I'm not making this up
you this this is really what according
to elected Democrats like Alexandra
occasional Cortez and Rasheeda Talib and
the rest of the squad according to them
that's that is hate again that's that's
bias you're not eating at a Chinese
restaurant of course you're not eating
at any restaurant now but but it's no
it's it's the it's the Chinese
restaurants that are being victimized
but I have to say I think Trump's
response was was great
I love the response he was rational cool
calm logical appropriately dismissive he
came off like a man who has more
important things to worry about which he
does so the approach and the tone in the
posture has been I think I think was
great there and in general this week has
been very good in my opinion with
respect to his response to the pandemic
and and to the media and Trump indicates
that he only made a point of saying
Chinese virus because China tried to
slander our true
by blaming them for it so Trump said
okay if that's how you guys want to play
it I'm gonna label this the Chinese
virus and that again is great I mean
that's exactly what a president should
be doing a president should get offended
on behalf of our soldiers and on behalf
of our people this is something that the
left still doesn't understand about
Trump and and his appeal for a lot of
people is that you know yeah he can be
very cruel and and and nasty towards
certain groups of people but those are
always the media politicians celebrities
other famous people you know that's who
he's going after people who oftentimes
number one deserve it and number two
they can take it given their station in
life but truck he's not he's doesn't go
after regular Americans you know when it
comes to American citizens he's not
going after them he's defending them
troops law enforcement those groups now
you you contrast that with what you get
from the left and where their contempt
is often directed and it's exactly the
opposite whether they're gonna direct
their contempt at those groups of normal
Americans while defending politicians
and celebrities and famous people now as
for the claim that it's racist to call
the Chinese virus well again I say
extremely stupid not to get tectal for
technical first of all but Chinese is
not a race a person can hate China all
they want and it still would not be
racist and you could hate the entire
country of China and you wouldn't be
racist in fact you could hate all
Chinese people which you shouldn't but
as a matter of technicality here it
would not be racist because that's not a
race may be bigoted prejudicial it's not
good but any case that's not what's
happening here
people aren't people don't hate all
Chinese people no one's taking it out on
Chinese people in general
nobody's going around thinking or saying
the Chinese people all Chinese people
are infected it's not what's happening
here
what some
people are pointing out as a simple fact
that the virus began its career in Wuhan
China a great many illnesses as have
been pointed out many times now have are
named after the places where they began
or after landmarks like the Ebola virus
is named after the Ebola River in Africa
got the German measles the West Nile
virus the Spanish flu in fact the
Spanish flu is is this the Spanish flu
didn't start in Spain it didn't hit
Spain particularly hard or didn't hit
Spain any harder than it hit other
countries there's no reason for it to be
called the Spanish flu it's just one of
the dozens of countries that were hit by
this planet by the flu and we decided to
call it the Spanish flu so they have a
complaint for this
I don't think China does but of course
there's more than just the mere
happenstance of China being the
epicenter of the disease the Chinese
government is in many ways responsible
for allowing the virus to spread so far
and rapidly because in the early days of
the outbreak they responded much like
the Soviets did with Chernobyl they they
moved slowly at first they were more
concerned with stopping the spread of
information about the the the disaster
than they were about actually stopping
it
medical experts were censored doctors
were prevented from warning the world
and and each other about the nature of
the disease and how serious it was some
of the early whistleblowers are now dead
but the fact that there had to be
whistleblowers in the first place should
tell you everything you need to know if
there have to be whistleblowers who are
doctors risking life and limb to tell
the world about this virus well that's
that's that shows you what's going on in
China and it's all the more reason why
the Chinese government deserves to get
the blame why shouldn't we hang this
around the Chinese government's neck and
make them wear it especially now that
they're attempting to turn the tables
and blame us
but of course the media is more than
happy to echo communist propaganda if it
means landing a blow on Trump and
but either way it started with China and
their dishonesty misdirection and
propaganda made it worse than it had to
be speaking of dishonesty misdirection
and propaganda they just think about
what the media is doing here imagine
being a reporter there's a pandemic
there are shutdowns and quarantines and
we're facing the prospect of a
depression extraordinary things are
happening very bad things are happening
it's a it is a it is a historic moment
in so many ways you have a chance to ask
the President of the United States a
question right to his face on TV I think
we all have many questions we would like
to ask of people in positions of
authority who maybe know more about us
you know know more about this situation
than we do because maybe they're privy
to information that we are not you have
a chance to ask a question and that's
what you ask you ask him why he's being
a big ol meanie head to China China as
Trump would say that that's your
question meanwhile there's another
reporter Chinese American reporter for I
believe CBS who claims that a White
House official called it the come flu
right to her face and this has been a
big controversy now she provided no
evidence for this at all she just
claimed it we're supposed to believe her
take her at her word because we all know
when it comes to claims the media makes
about the Trump administration those are
always reliable we should always trust
those but what difference does it make
it's a quote Hillary Clinton what
different what what difference at this
point does it make if that was said or
not why should we even care okay so
let's let's say that someone did say
that who cares get over it get the hell
over it get over yourself it's not
important it really isn't
you know if this was
disease that originated in the American
South and people were calling it the I
don't know calling it redneck itis or
something you wouldn't be complaining
that reporter wouldn't be complaining no
reporter would be complaining they'd be
joining in the fun and we all know it so
yeah just get over yourself and then of
course here's Richard Engel NBC's
foreign correspondent in he's on NBC
he's lecturing Americans on this on this
issue which we should all listen to him
because he's important watch it is easy
to scapegoat
people and that is what has always
happened when there have been pandemics
or epidemics that foreigners are are
attacked foreigners sometimes physically
attacked if you look at what happened
there during the Middle Ages there was
lots and lots of scapegoating against an
ethnic group or a religious group
whenever there were pandemics that
affected the society and frightened a
lot of people and China certainly feels
that is what happened what is happening
now with people calling it the the Wuhan
flu or the Wuhan virus or the the China
virus this is a virus that came from the
territory of China but came from bats
this is a bat virus not a China virus it
doesn't speak Chinese
it doesn't target Chinese people it
targets human beings who happen to touch
their eyes nose or mouth oh it doesn't
speak Chinese really is that so richard
engel i had no idea thank you for that
information because I had no idea
I thought the virus itself I thought
what a virus infects you it walks up to
you and speaks to you in whatever
language of the country of itself it's
originated and then you have a
conversation and then you and then you
you engage in hand-to-hand battle with
the virus and only if it defeats you in
that battle does it does it then enter
your body and and take control I thought
that's how it works but but apparently
not okay so the China virus doesn't
speak Chinese the Spanish flu doesn't
speak Spanish I guess next you're gonna
tell me that my French bread in my
kitchen doesn't speak French that
explains a lot because I was up all
night trying to talk to my French bread
trying to carry on a conversation was
being pretty rude giving me the cold
shoulder
and he's right that he says that it
comes to came from bats but how did it
get from a bat into a person let me ask
you that see the thing is most likely if
there was a bat in this country that had
the China flu it probably wouldn't make
it from the bat into a person and why is
that because we don't eat bats in China
they do and and eating bats is an
objectively disgusting unhealthy
practice so like it or not this pandemic
originates from comes from the dangerous
and gross eating habits of some of the
folks in that part of the world world
and once again I say if people in the
American South of white people in
American South had a habit of eating
bats and then a pandemic started because
of that what do you think the media
would be saying you think they'd be
saying oh no we can't talk about that we
can't talk about the fact that this
originates from from rednecks in the
south no no we're not gonna discuss that
no way let's that's inappropriate guys
come on you think take me saying that no
the media will never admit that it has
any responsibility here but the fact is
that this is why there's been so much
confusion and division and debate about
the virus and what we should do about it
how severe it is because nobody can
trust the sources of information that's
what I was talking about on my show at
the beginning of the week that there's a
crisis of trust
who should you listen to these people
these ridiculous smarmy jackasses who
have spent a week now crying about the
name that people are using for a disease
that just shut down half the globe and
we're gonna trust them no we can't so
who then do you trust there's no use
being in an Information Age if your
sources of information are manifestly
unreliable then it's more of a
disinformation agent that's what we're
living in the disinformation age and
then when you have a pandemic on top of
that and people want they simply want to
know what's happening what should I do
you've got nowhere to turn and so this
goes back to the media and that's and
that
balls in their shoulders but of course
they'll never accept blame for that
we're gonna go to your fight five
headlines in a second but first if you
haven't had a chance to see some of the
new content we started this week over at
the Daily wire you should go and check
it out especially the all-access live
show and you can find that daily
wire.com and catch up you can watch now
they it's right there in the title of
course the show the it does it does
happen live but you can go and watch the
videos if you missed it
Jeremy boring and ben shapiro kicked off
Monday evening Jeremy and Michael
Knowles followed up on Tuesday night and
then I did a live stream last night
which if you didn't watch it then you
missed me playing another original
composition from my banjo that has a lot
of people in the live stream were
bugging me the entire time play the
banjo and I did and I think anyone that
was on the live stream they were all
saying that it was absolutely beautiful
and they feel like their life has been
changed from seeing my performance you
missed it if you didn't watch though you
don't want to miss stuff like this will
be doing episodes the rest of this week
at 8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific
all-access live is unique programming at
the Daily wire usually our podcasts are
highly produced on these sorts of
stunning very expensive sets like the
one that you can see here which is just
my house my a room in my own house but
this is different it's a more casual
environment
that's because the focus isn't on
production value is just on connecting
with you guys and having a conversation
very interactive it was actually
intended for our all-access members but
in order to help us all feel a little
bit less lonely during this time of
being quarantined we accelerated the
launch and we open it up to all of our
daily wire members for the time being so
their daily wire remember you can take
part in this I would really recommend it
and if you're around at 8 p.m. Eastern
5:00 p.m. Pacific tonight you could join
us again on the all-access live show at
Daley wire.com okay
headlines number one reading from
Breitbart says New Orleans Mayor Latoya
Cantrell signed a coronavirus emergency
order last week allowing her to ban the
sale and transportation of firearms she
signed a follow up Proclamation on March
16 2020 further emphasizing her
emergency powers to suspend or limit the
sale dispensing or
imitation of alcoholic beverages the
declaration declaring the mayor's power
to restricted gun sales and
transportation says that she is quote
empowered if necessary to suspend or
limit the sale of alcoholic beverages
firearms explosives and combustibles now
this is clearly nothing more or less
than a left-wing political operative
taking advantage of a national emergency
to impose her ideological agenda by Fiat
and grab power for herself there is no
conceivable reason why the sale of guns
would need to be banned during a
situation like this and in any case it's
not about need anyway because the Second
Amendment Second Amendment is still a
thing that still exists so this isn't
even a conversation about need but I'm
making the point that there isn't any
connection between the come flu and this
except in the other direction which is
that it may be all the more reason why
you would want to bear arms especially
when you consider what's happening in
some other cities like in Philadelphia
where they're telling cops not to
enforce the law even law is like theft
don't enforce it don't arrest people for
that well if you're at a city like that
then you've basically been told by the
police it's up to you to protect your
belongings
number two the Daily wire reports on
Wednesday after seven young after seven
people were shot in Baltimore on Tuesday
night's Baltimore Mayor Jack young
pleaded with residents to stop shooting
each other so that there would be beds
available for victims of the coronavirus
on Wednesday but Baltimore reported a
fifth person who had been infected with
the virus the Baltimore Sun reported the
five confirmed cases in Baltimore
involve a person in their 60s a person
in their 20s and three people in there
or a person in their 70s and three
people in their twenties all are in good
to stable condition but he's just urging
people he's pleading with them not to
shoot each other this is what it's come
to in Baltimore that you've just got
mayor's begging begging people not to
shoot each other but remember this is
Baltimore we're talking about we're
talking about decades of Democratic
leadership which speaking
of not being accountable not not not
taking responsibility do you think the
Democratic Party is ever going to take
responsibility for the fact that in most
of these cities across the country that
are crime riddled and falling apart they
are they have been led by Democrats for
decades now of course not it's somehow
it's still the fault of you know the
racist conservatives number three MSN
reports US immigration authorities will
temporarily halt enforcement across the
United States except for its efforts to
deport foreign nationals who have
committed crimes the change in
enforcement status comes amid the corona
virus outbreak and aims to limit the
spread of the virus and to encourage
those who need treatment to seek help so
we're gonna limit the spread of the
virus by not stopping people who come
here illegally from other countries
that's how we're gonna limit the
pandemic makes sense great number four
Liz oh is now calling out tik-tok
accusing the site of censoring photos of
her in a bathe in bathing suits
she says that apparently when she puts
up a photo of herself in a bikini
mysteriously it keeps getting taken down
or I guess is this is tick-tock so it'd
be a video I don't know I don't know
kids I've never used the site one of it
one of them their social media sites but
she says they're censoring the footage
of her your bathing suit all I can say
is you know sometimes censorship is not
such a bad thing that's all I'll say
number five here's something that really
should be censored case in point this is
so bad that it has made me rethink my
support of the First Amendment you could
make an argument for abolishing the firt
the First Amendment simply to prevent
something like this from happening again
this is gal gadot and her celebrity pals
they've all gotten together well not
physically together but they've all
decided to compile a video that they
hope will inspire us in this very trying
time and I don't know you watch it and
let me know if you're inspired it isn't
hard to do yeah that it you can't get
through it you just can't you have to
look away this is I don't know if I I
mean do you think you could get them
with that videos two minutes long do you
think you could watch could you
physically handle watching that whole
video I cringe so hard watching that
that I collapsed into myself and I was
absorbed into myself and I turned into a
black hole and then I consumed the
galaxy and we are now all living in an
alternate alternate dimension that's
what happened in the 45 seconds of
watching that video and I only played
part of it I feel like we need to watch
more I'm sorry but we need to watch more
this is penance this is punishment for
our sins repent repent ye sinners we'll
watch a little more but let's see you
may say
but I'm not the only one I hope someday
you will join us imagine no no need for
greed and hunger brotherhood of man okay
I can't I can't do it anymore that's it
that's all I can do I can't I can't go
further than that of course they choose
the worst song of all time John Lennon
and Lenin imagine it's the worst song
the dumbest song and they're singing
imagine no posessions celebrities in
their expensive clothes and their fancy
mansions in Beverly Hills quarantined in
their mansions in Beverly Hills they're
they're telling us imagine no posessions
right but I want to go back and I do
want to break that was a couple of
things in this video that I think need
to be analyzed a little bit closer so I
want to break this down a couple things
first of all let's go back to Natalie
Portman's
part of the video nothing they kill or
die for so yeah I'm surprised by that
because didn't you expect her to have a
good singing voice that's a little bit
shocking I didn't expect her to be
tone-deaf I think you always expect
pretty women to have good singing voices
you you figure that's part of the
package but apparently not in all cases
and then I don't know who this person is
but I'm I'm very confused here
[Music]
so yeah I don't know who that is I don't
know half who half of the people in the
video are but she's taking this way too
seriously everyone else is basically
mumbling as they're walking to their car
but she's in there auditioning for
American Idol though I have to say who
among us who among us does not every
once in a while stand in the bathroom
taking a selfie video of themselves
singing a John Lennon song who among us
oh you guys haven't well no me neither
I was just kidding I wouldn't I wouldn't
do that that'd be really weird and
finally um you know this is not supposed
to be funny I'm just concerned can we
take a look at Will Ferrell we don't
have to play the part of him again but
just look at the screen shot he looks
like he's been in quarantine since 1952
alternatively he looks like me after my
wife's been out of town for like 36
hours that's what I look like everything
has just gone gone to hell I think
someone needs to check on him but the
thing is nobody can check on him because
we're all in quarantine so you're on
your own we'll hang in there
imagine imagine there's no heaven which
ironically indeed is not hard to do
after watching a video like that let me
just say one other thing about this I
was making fun of it on online today and
some people were saying what do you what
are you making fun of it for these are
just people they're trying to inspire us
hey you don't have to be so cynical
first of all I do have to be so cynical
it's in my nature second of all I'm
making fun of it because it's it's it's
funny third you know not to be cynical
but why would the celebrities think that
it's a good idea to put this video out
why would they do you think a bunch of
Joe schmo's would ever consider
compiling video a video of them singing
different parts of imagine tone-deaf
acapella and then put it online no
nobody would do that no normal person
would do that because there's no reason
to make that video it's it's awful the
only reason they made it is because
figured well we're celebrities and so
even if it's bad and we can't sing and
there's nothing good about this video
and no reason for it to exist we're
celebrities and so people will like it
people will be inspired because it's
celebrities doing it we're famous people
it's it's inspiring because we are
famous people trying to inspire you and
if we're trying to inspire you you damn
well better be inspired that's the
attitude but I don't like this it's
self-important it's very self-important
and also hilarious all right let's move
on to your daily cancelation I will be
unfortunately sadly with great
trepidation and perhaps a great personal
cost I will be cancelling my wife my
wife is cancelled now I have to keep my
voice down because as I mentioned we are
all self quarantined right now my whole
family is in the house as I speak so
this is her official notification of her
cancellation let me explain as I as I
air my marital dirty laundry for for
everyone to experience now it's a bit of
a it's a bit of a saga so you have to
you have to stay with me here
but once that once I get there you'll
understand so it begins with my daughter
a few days ago
losing a tooth she lost a tooth and she
was very excited about it as kids tend
to be so I asked her I said hey bet you
can't wait for the Tooth Fairy tonight
and then she said and I wasn't expecting
this she said Oh daddy I'm not sure if
the Tooth Fairy is real and I said what
what do you mean not real why would you
say that and she said well the last two
times I had a tooth under my pillow the
Tooth Fairy didn't come and I just woke
up when the tooth was still there so I
don't think she's real now at this point
of course I'm realizing the oversight
I'm realizing that I forgot to leave the
money twice and I'm wracked with guilt
and I'm racked with guilt especially
because my daughter she never told us
like she'd make up and start crying and
whining that the tooth fairy didn't come
she just
apparently she just silently suffered
she felt her disappointment and
dejection silently and that somehow
makes it even worse because all parents
of young kids know
that when they whine about something
your sympathy for them immediately
evaporates no matter what it is when
they're using the whiny voices you have
no sympathy but when they're upset when
they're really upset about something and
they're they're not whining and they're
just sort of silently devastated that's
when it that's when it gets you right in
the heart okay and that's that's how I
felt so I felt like I you know I had to
come up with an excuse and I said well
honey you know the the tooth fairy's a
deadbeat constantly forgetting so it
happens to everybody now the great thing
about having a child who believes in
mythical creatures is that you could
always blame them for your failures and
I I'm doing this all the time the tooth
fairy's messing things up Santa Claus is
the Easter Bunny leprechauns
unicorns they're making all kinds of
mistakes in this house I never do daddy
never does if there's a mistake made
it's one of them now sidebar here I'm
not sure why we're even doing the Tooth
Fairy thing in my house I don't know why
we're doing it it's a very weird
tradition I mean think about what you're
telling kids you're telling your kid
that a supernatural entity sneaks into
their room at night and steals their
teeth whoever thought of this why are we
telling our kids this this entity this
creature apparently has a whole stash of
billions of teeth has billions of teeth
of children like in a lair somewhere
under the earth I don't know you know
hidden in a volcano I don't know where
she puts it all and it's it's horrifying
it's completely ridiculous as well which
is why I suspect and I'm trying to think
where did this tradition come from
I think this tradition originates as
sort of an early IQ test for kids
because by the time they're old enough
to lose their teeth they should be old
enough to sense that this story is
absurd and can't possibly be true now my
daughter has passed that test because
she's you know she's at the age where
she's losing the teeth and she said yeah
I don't know about this tooth fairy deal
my son on the other hand has not passed
the test and and I love him to death
he's a he's a sweet boy but he's a
simple child which is what I love about
him you know but he'll believe any story
you tell him yeah I could tell him that
a magical flying warthog named Edwin
comes into the kitchen at night and does
our dishes and he would believe it right
away it oughta
he would buy into my my daughter his
twin sister is a bit of a skeptic though
anyway so my daughter is suspecting she
suspects something but she hasn't
completely given up her belief in the
tooth fairy so after she goes to bed my
wife tells me that I need to go into the
room before I you know she says remember
before you go to bed I don't know why my
wife couldn't do it but you know that's
the way it goes
says make sure you go into the room and
leave some money under the pillow and so
I said okay I'll do that
and I so I go in there and at night and
I try to you know I'm reaching my hand
at the pillow my daughter wakes up sits
up in bed like as if she'd been waiting
for me which she probably had been and
she says what are you doing daddy and I
didn't have an answer ready I said oh I
was uh I was I was just I was gonna
fluff your pillow I was coming in to
fluff the bad guy if I fluffed I fluffed
the pillows at night that's why I do I
go around fluff all the pillows at night
so that's what that's what I was doing
and she looked at me like she didn't
believe me ha but she goes back to bed
and and in the morning she brings us up
to my wife to you know to mommy and
tells her tells mommy what happened what
she caught me doing trying to figure out
she's suspicious she started to think
maybe daddy is a tooth fairy and then my
wife tells her my wife for some reason
who is desperate to preserve my
daughter's belief in the psychotic
serial killing demon who steals teeth
tells her that no no no daddy's not the
tooth fairy daddy was coming in to steal
the money that the Tooth Fairy left you
my wife decided that it'd be better for
my daughter to believe that her dad is a
thief
who sneaks into the room at night to
steal her possessions then it would be
to just tell her the Tooth Fairy isn't
real I told you it was a long story to
get there but it's it's important
and so that's why my wife has canceled
and I have been told I cannot tell my
you know I can't I I'm denying it I'm
saying look I got my own money you think
I'm gonna steal your money your money is
my money where do you think you got your
money from if I want to steal money from
you I would just keep my own money and
not give it to you anyway we've been
coordinating for a long time these are
the kind of disputes that happen I think
we'll leave it that I was gonna do
emails but then I decided to talk about
the Tooth Fairy for 25 minutes and so
we'll have to just end it there a lot of
interesting emails we'll save for
tomorrow tomorrow is the I should remind
you that no Korona show at least that's
the tentative plan no mention of
coronavirus in the show tomorrow we're
to think about other things to talk
about maybe we'll talk about the Tooth
Fairy for another hour who knows but
thanks everybody for watching stay safe
out there
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]